oh wow wipeout
hello and welcome to add guide to Need
for Speed payback
brought to you by EA I'm dan Mar and I'm
joined by Yanni who you might know from
the massive YouTube channel Janna mais
yeah but he could see you now I thought
for our first episode in this series of
payback videos we throw you and write
the deep end okay
driving these amazing supercars drivers
making hyper cars but a lot of time in
skåne you gonna be on the wrong side of
the law as well I thought what I'd do is
for your first exposure I throw you
straight into into a chase okay so the
police adjacent waits on your back you
are in an experimental new prototype car
average speed bout hundred six hundred
seven miles an hour okay see any girl
really yeah you ready to go let's do it
let's go I start follow the arrows and
there the police there they are
five-oh dead ahead you guys so every
time you oh wow yeah don't don't be are
you wrecked one of the cop cars already
that's it don't good get them out of it
think about this game this is not this
is not serious driving you know the idea
is is to silence the cars unless they're
planning to you and get them up the road
at the same time you're gonna pick these
RT as well because they're your
checkpoints that's been a key to
changing I'm in a hyper car they've gone
look at me look at the speed of this
oh wow see they hold on oh my friends I
know so you've tagged into this on the
car so now you're one of the other races
yes the m4 is a lot tighter it handles
really really well kind of thing with
all-over rope yep top in speed all
another one gone just rear-ended that
one in two it was just um buckets one
wrecked nice this is quite sensible
carcasses Oh beautiful that's what you
get for taking one of his colleagues
down it's a roadblock ahead probably
effective one pretty huge gap in the
middle yeah sort of defeats the purpose
of a roadblock to the cars together yeah
taking the end before do the jump I've
been trained you back in that looks like
it nice we made it I think you did it so
this is a man Rob who's our mechanic
rats man down what have you done
didn't ref tell you what's under that
hood my buyers are paying a fortune for
it you'll never get away with this devar
oh she's taking the car so okay so
unfortunately you're now in a skyline i
me a skyline instead thousand four
horsepower Oh
so obviously this is go through so
obviously this isn't don't like war
simulation but I mean does the kind of
handling with these cars barely
resemblance to how they are in real life
the GTR was very much so good 54 there
are 30 for you he's just twitchy the
skyline is so so twitchy in real life as
well
the m3 does handle well so you've only
got a thousand yards to go and you've
outrun the crops then it for in the
clock I think you lose country
so well the first or first goat look at
the nitrous I love when that nitrous
kick Syrian war it surges the car
forward but the visual feedback is
really it's real right as well as not
just like that added blur just gives
that sense of it
these speakers will be running got it I
gotta say did you did well thank you
very hard on the law first time it's a
good start
aced it right well join us in the next
video where we're gonna be looking at
needless be paybacks Street leagues see
you then